You know, when we kinda get caught up in the minutia,...
...the details that make us all different, I think there's two ways of seeing that.
There's an opportunity to see the texture of that person,...
...the characteristics that make them unique.
And then, there's an opportunity to go to war about it,...
...to say that person is different from me and "I don't like you, so let's battle."
My mother is an ordained minister.
I'm a Muslim.
She didn't do backflips when I called her to tell her I converted 17 years ago.
But I tell you now, we put things to the side...
...and I was able to see her, she's able to see me.
We love each other.
The love has grown.
And that stuff is minutia.
It's not that important.